hi everyone my name is in Kali today I'm
going to talk about making options
robots to office markets this is a joint
work with Moshi Baba nikoi Malika and
Brandon Lucia
so our problem is about auction design
and more specifically we consider a
situation where our principle tries to
allocate discussed resources to buyers
whose primary values for those resources
and the goal of the principle is try to
find the maximum data maximize the
location efficiency
there has been many classic solutions to
this program which includes second price
auction whether it's just a single item
or using uniform price auction where
there are multiple units of the
identical items
one of the crucial features that are
missing in those the classical option
design is the presence of RC markets
in many practice situations of the
auction concludes the buyers can
actually try to resell the items they
have acquired in the aftermarkets
and what's the impact of art markets on
the organization efficiency
first knows that giving any fixed or
location after the auction concludes the
research always improves the efficiency
this is because integration it can only
happen that the item is transfers from
low value bars to high value bars in
order to satisfy their incentives and
this transaction always includes the
efficiency
however another effect of the
aftermarket that the possibility of
Borussia can actually change spice
behavior in the primary option and this
changing Behavior can actually have a
detrimental effect on the overall
equilibrium efficiency
so aftermarkets have ambiguous effects
on the overall equipping equivalency and
the main goal of our papers try to study
this the efficiencies designed with
aftermarkets
and a lot of that uh
which challenges in doing that is that
in many applications in practice
actually the auction designer may not
have control over the aftermarket or
even worse in some specifications the
principle does not have even knowledge
about the aftermarket this is because
for any pair of buyers they can
privately Trace their items acquiring
instruction with the terms that see
practices negotiated
as a principle which we don't have exact
knowledge about the detailed negotiated
terms
and health our goal here for this talk
let's try to show you how to make the
awkward design with distribution
security guarantee that I will pass to
the exact details so much of the
aftermarket
uh see me application we have in mind
that actually motivates us to send this
third question and see copying emission
allows auctions
nowadays the carbon dioxide actually
contributes the light fraction to the
greenhouse we get and this is also a
leading structure that causes global
warming and nowadays in Europe the
organization of beauty is actually
designs medicine for certain carbon
emission analysis and first we need to
first purchase the license in order to
legally emit the carbon dioxide into the
atmosphere
the current medicine that has been
adopted by uets is uniform price auction
that has many benefits for example
transparency means that as a low
function all the virus no surprises
assets for other buyers in order to win
the item
and also has those benefits of price to
recovery meaning the prices thus
fastening these items actually changed
automatically as the realizes the amount
of virus changes
and in this couple initial options
usually there are markets that allows
the people to retrieve the items
acquired from Central auction as the
addition compensates for allowing such
after markets as I said it can provide
insurance for uncertainty in demos
for example if there is a firm that
realized he has more demons than he
actually acquires Prime auction he is
able to actually purchase more license
in the aftermarkets
but the additional existence of art
markets also with the concern because it
opens room for speculation speculators
can try to give the system to make
progress but this give me all Behavior
can actually distort the audition and
leads to a worthy equilibrium outcome
thanks
and here our paper we show that actually
this is
a realistic concern for the current
system because the current adopt uniform
price auction is not going to be your
best to ask markets and space relation
place a crucial role here first Market
and in order to restore the efficient
allocation outcome we are going to
propose three alternative solutions that
provides the robustness on efficiency
outcomes
these three solutions I respected are
smooth sections uh positive prices and
finally using uniform price option but
with additional Anonymous reserves there
are benefits and drawbacks for each of
those Solutions and I'm going to
elaborate on some later in this talk but
eventually I'm going to show that our
final recommendation is the last
solution which is using uniform price
auction with a non-suit service
before moving out to the results uh let
me give you a little bit more detail on
the exact model we are going to study
here the prince will try to sell and
units of an identical good to end
different buyers
each buyer I is going to have a
decreasing marginal violations for the
munis and these violations are drawn
independently from distribution effort
the whole Market has two components the
primary auction and the aftermarkets the
principle can decide what happens in
primary auction but does not have any
control over the aftermarkets
more specifically the principle can
decide what are the allocation and the
payments group that can be implemented
in the private auction and at the end of
the Prime worksheet each individual
buyer is going to privately observe its
own allocation and his payment to the
principle
and in the office Market we are not
going to make any structural assumption
on the format of the aftermarket we are
going to only post two weak assumptions
to ensure that the draft Market has
actually reasonable to exist in practice
uh the first assumption we made is
budget balance meaning the supremists in
the aftermarkets it just transfers from
one bar to another star uh it's means
that there cannot exist any
Health Science Source who doesn't care
about the licenses wants to put money
into the system and buy all the license
from the existing virus
and the second assumption we made is
voluntary participation let's see
essentially ensures that all the agents
has the option to just opt out the
aftermarket and keep the whatever
allocation he has the required from the
primary auction
so
and since this Market structure has two
stages the solution Concepts we adopted
the perfect patient equilibrium that
ensures sequential rationality in the
multi-stage games
but note that your positive results I'm
going to show you in a bit all of those
three business results holds even for
the weaker solution concept of Bayesian
Action Group okay
uh here in our problem the goal of the
priest was try to maximize The crucial
efficiency
uh with
this image the measure of experience we
adopt as price organic for any maximum
suppressor of Anarchy is defined as
maximum ratio between the optimal
welfare and the worst case equilibrium
buffer given the maximum end was the
maximum is taking over all possible
distribution over valuations of other
agents
but
so using this the measure of features
let's first look at the healthy country
adult mechanism which is uniform price
auction performs on this measure
into some uniform price auction buyers
are going to submit their bits for each
additional unit they want to read from
the option
and then the items are sold to the
Empire speeds this is Max to clean price
which is set to be equal to the M plus
price high speed
from the previous work we know that if
we just try to run this uniform price
auction without traffic markers uh the
location efficiency is actually quite
good the price of Anarchy is just as
most e over U minus one
and this is another assumption that all
buyers are choosing all dominated
strategies which is very reasonable
because
usually practices we don't observe that
players are choosing dominated strategy
and this shows that actually useful
price also works well while applying
isolation and this is probably wealth
justification wise country adopted in
the UA test
however we show that it the market can
break down when there are aftermarkets
uh in the worst case the price of
Anarchy when there are aftermarkets can
actually be as large as the order of log
m y m is number of items that the
principle tries to set
here is an example of that your stress
the ones the market experience and the
price of Anarchy is quite large
in this example there are three parts
where a and five b are actually buys
such various item but it has high value
post Joshua item but still for the rest
of item but here are available
here the Speculator it doesn't value the
licenses he just tried to
buy from auction with your invest Market
to make some profit
um due to the element of type I'm not
going to tell you about the details
construction of the equilibrium but very
briefly speaking what can happen in
equilibrium is that the Speculator can
make profits from making very high
passing promotion and research to other
buyers for profit in the aftermarket
and in order for the Speculator to make
uh to maximize his profits he is trying
to set a realistic high price in the
aftermarket which can distort the
location efficiency and leads to low
equilibrium weather
if this illustrates that the aftermarket
can be quite detrimental to the location
efficiency
uh while running the usual price of well
another question to ask is whether this
construction of the equipment is
reasonable
uh to concern might be that for example
in singlet motion by running second
Quest
it's like uh statistics expects us the
allocation outcome is efficient but
there could exist some equilibrium work
low validation make hybrids such as
diatomas allocated to the low validator
with the lower prescription buffer but
in such example
people uh the agents are using dominated
strategies and there's this important to
check with this is the case in our
equipment Construction
and we are going to show you that that's
not okay
uh one thing we can observe in uniform
path option is that the virus May
strictly benefits from shading surface
this is case Over By A and B here both
bars actually are going to win Rising
the primary auction the laboratory
choose to make the low beds for the rest
of units in order to win the item with
low prices
such as their utility is maximum
and the justification for the Speculator
to make a hybrids even though he does
not have any balances item is that there
are actually complementary authorities
in the revenue for the Speculator in
that markets for among we need items
this
the suggest that so what happens here is
that
for this Speculator he can have a large
Revenue
only if he
attributes a lot of items in primary
auction if we lose uh even just one
items in his auction then the revenue of
this Speculator in that market can be
significantly reduces
and the justification for him to making
such hybrids as just to ensure that he
can actually win a lot of items
for with your involved markets and this
strategy is not a dominant strategy and
combining these two points we can see
that actually our Construction Group is
actually very reasonable
this further confirms the
crucial issue of the
long robustness of uniform price auction
when they are aftermarkets
in order to resolve this the welfare
issue we are going to propose three
solutions
first solution we are going to talk
about is the smooth option
an example of the most auction is using
the discriminator auction
in this two indiscriminator auction but
still submits their bits for each
additional units you want to bring into
primary option and the asthma still sold
to them high speed
the main difference is that the prices
are not set to be equal to each
individual bias marginal bits for the
right
this is discrimination is a special case
of what we call more generally uh the
most options and we see us make them as
Lamborghi with large enough utility
expressed as in this following
expression
I'm not going to give you details on
this expression but intrinsically what
he suggested that in equilibrium the
loss is Welfare by deviating from the
efficient location can always be partly
offset by the auxiliary group this
ensures the overall equilibrium
allocation efficiency
and as we have seen from previous work
any massage that are wrong without
aftermarket a flow price open the key
which is at most view Overland
and in your paper we show that this
result is actually robust when there are
two markets meaning that is the
principle runs the primary options such
as London view smooth then the price of
Anarchy of the combined Market has also
utmost to be Overland
straightforward
uh we can just simply view the combined
Market as a very large magnitude where
agents need to mix the crucial decisions
and we only need to find our good
division strategy for each student
required to show that this large
mechanism is actually smooth
this division structure Constructor as
follows the agent can choose to follow
the same division strategy as if the
primary option is wrong you stand alone
results aftermarkets and after she gets
no location please ask Market they can
just choose not to trade
and we can directly show that it can
ensures a large enough to utility of the
bar and has the whole life Negative Edge
family memes
and apply the existing results this
smoothness of large mechanism as the low
price automatic
there are some additional benefits of
actual adopting this option so so in
addition to the console of path markets
you made an applications but can also to
invest to actually learn about other
bias value and make betting strategies
accordingly and we show that it's the
peaceful use small circuits than to
combined Market also have constant price
of vanity events with the presence of
this Espionage Behavior
but certainly there are some drawbacks
of using this mechanism both drawbacks
is that it has very complex strategic
optimization requirements for each
individual device
and if we want to run this in practice
it would be make it very difficult both
more forms to participate because those
small firm does not have research powers
to estimate market demand and make us
the optimal bidding decisions
so
this is the drawback of massage and next
I'm going to tell you about our second
football solution
this solution is
have very simple option formats
here the prince will just try to set
multiple prices for each team units that
he wants to sell and the parents are in
practice especially and as far as can
make the purchase decisions until the
items close up
there has been many Works installation
that provides the robust to welfare
guarantees results after market
but in your paper will show that not all
those prices works with the existing of
Park Market
uh This Is The Limited type I'm not
going to tell you about why those other
approaching well they said I'm going to
tell you on a sixth a successful
approach which is using balanced price
the definition of balance price makes
the requirement sense first the prices
should be high enough maybe that's price
paid for any other patient should be at
least the loss we often will offer due
to losing those items and this is more
funded up to a concert in fact
multiplicative constant Factor
this insurance that giving this best
prices whatever the agents purchased
item has always generates a large enough
to refer to the overall also type
and also surprises should be low enough
means that the total price of any
allocation that remains feasible after
allocated X
uh should be at most often worth the
cheaper whose items that are not
allocated
this ensures that given this process
through many items can still be sold to
the agent with reasonable welfare
guarantee
and so
a price sector is balanced if both
conditions are satisfied
and we show that using the stylus prices
for any aftermarket
the price of vanity of this combined
Market is always a cost
the main reason why we can generalize
the results from auctions with us
aftermarket two situation with option
aftermarket that's because the prices
are set should be logging
this means that whatever and unit is
sold to a speculations option
in order to rationalize the speculative
Behavior this might item must be
resolved to another by that market with
high enough value
So eventually this item is going to end
up with someone who values the multiple
items this ensures that
the overall efficiency is quite High
regardless of soft Market
and we also show that balance prices
actually exist so when buyers have
decreasing marginal values
and there are additional benefits of
using this one of them is that it has
low strategic requirements the path just
needs to compress the marginal value for
the item with the marginal price
but also there are some drawbacks of
using this whole surprising negative
first is a huge change compared to the
current Solutions so there might be
legislation challenges for actually
adopting this and also it lacks the
benefits of practicals perfect because
the price prices are starting at a month
and it cannot change according to the
Reliance market tomorrow
and therefore we are going to move on to
our final solution which is what we
recommend for implementing practice
so the solution is still using the
uniform price option plus buyer can only
wins is marginal bit as above the prices
and we show that if we use the bias
devices IG Reserve as to the agents
actually giving any aftermarket the
price of energy of this combined Market
can always be insured to be a cost
and we in addition we show that
actually an enormous truth of is
sufficient but also bias has decreasing
marginal revenue that decreasing
marginal values this are normally
reserves the insurance amongst other
buyers that participating in the game
we also see that this proposed Solutions
have many additional benefits yes so
much change compared to the current
system because we only need to introduce
an enormous research let's enhancement
benefits from the usual price for
auction for example the breasted fabric
because this price can be adjusted
alcohol nutrition
and finally uh we know that in order to
find a good enough Reserve process the
question between these two estimate the
open wireframes for allocating item
optimally but we show that emails the
estimations the slightly Incorrect and
we using correct solution for calculus
reserve the water loss due to the error
is actually question
so that's all for my talk thanks
everyone for attending